stefan flückiger hegt eine leidenschaft
für verlassene gebäude ein urban
explorer zu seinem neuesten fund nimmt
er uns mit seit sechs jahren spürte
gebäude auf die keiner mehr braucht
er hält sie fest bevor sie zerbrechen
von der landkarte verschwinden
irgendwo im val de travers eine
stillgelegte fabrik seit über 30 jahren
steht sie leer
einst wurden hier offen ring gereizt im
asphalt herzustellen wo früher
geschuftet und geschwitzt wurde ist es
heute kalt und feucht
stefan flückiger will als erster zeigen
was noch vor seiner linse war
darum geht es ihm beim erben exploring
und auch um etwas nervenkitzel und
energie ist sondern die atmosphäre war
super
still ist es an diesem verlassenen orten
die seltsam zwischen vergangenheit und
gegenwart liegen im schatten jeder
aufmerksamkeit abenteuer und
missionsarbeit das noch festhalten fast
verschwindet das mache altes objekt zu
sein
oft scheint es als wären die menschen
vor kurzem erst gegangen
auf seinen bildern begegnet man
gegenständen die jahrzehnte überdauert
haben
denn allerdings ab und weil der nach
zwei stunden auch von mir
bush handel also wer weiß irgendwann
spaziert für seine bilder bewegt er sich
am rande der legalität heikle
situationen gehören dazu
als in einer alten schuhfabrik einstieg
stieß auf ein motiv das ihm bis heute
ein rätsel bleibt
alles was von diesen abenteuern bleibt
sind fotos
denn unter erben explorern gilt eine
eiserne regel dass es wichtig dass muss
haushaltet dessen druck die gebäude so
ist sie deshalb lieber die fabrik ist
wieder verlassen wenn sie morgen
vielleicht abgerissen wird ist stefan
flückiger schon auf der suche nach dem
nächsten objekt